ce sera une performance à couper le
souffle ce samedi 9 décembre à saint cyr
l'école
andy cabreira avila 46 ans tentera de
repousser les limites du corps humain à
10h30 précises le franco cubain
s'élancera pour réaliser des longueurs
de 25 mètres en apnée pendant 24 heures
un record qui nécessite un entraînement
minutieux des poèmes à septembre
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser barre de
façon spécifique à cette épreuve dames
blanches longue et combine l'amener à
sic et l'amener dans l'eau avec des
palmes des fois de gêne vraiment qu'un
de nos joueurs trois heures sur
l'objectif réalisé 42 km la distance
d'un marathon 24 heures pour tenir
physiquement l'apnéiste s'arrêtera
toutes les 10 minutes pour boire et
s'alimenter pendant une minute
celui que l'on surnomme le têtard de
cuba devrait également dormir quelques
minutes pendant la nuit la plus grande
difficulté c'est les crampes
parce que liée à l'effort de grandes
lans de longue durée
on peut avoir des crampes dans les pieds
et donc il faut boire beaucoup il faut
s'hydrater constamment donc si la pole
en difficulté au delà de la performance
l'exploit dandy a pour but de récolter
des dons en faveur du 31e téléthon les
animations ouvertes à tous sur le thème
de l'eau seront proposées en parallèle
dans la piscine
donc avec anne auront pour faire une
soirée aquagym que des fois ça coûte 15
euros
on a fait du vélo dans l'eau d'aquabike
les concours des nages fondation des
concours de la longueur l'amener tout
simplement fait un dos et la deûle à
participer à toutes les activités
à la sortie de son exploit en dise pas
récolté plusieurs milliers d'euros pour
la manifestation solidaire sa
performance quand elle pourrait être
enregistrée dans le guinness book des
records